yeah what else you can imagine it has
gone absolutely bananas here we're on
one of our main streets and uh this is
where the Lula uh supporters have been
here now for hours as it's a painstaking
countdown took place
um you know inching in with figures over
the last a bit of time they can't I
don't think many of them really can't
quite believe uh what has happened here
um they are hoping that Lula will come
down and it does
it is something of a remarkable comeback
you know Lula was a twice president of
Brazil he was one of the most popular
political figures in the world then he
decided to retire and then he got sent
to prison that that was quashed and now
he's come out against bolsonaro key I
think though over the next few hours and
days is does bolsonaro go along with
this it is really really close he's
already said that he thinks it's rigged
so will he try to go to the court anyway
a remarkable atmosphere I've joined by
this lady who's we just met in the crown
why does this mean so much to everyone
okay you know what's happened during the
pandemic
oh you don't have a scene more than 700
000 people die
and this President we know him like a
genocide
because we don't have support
human support that's that's the reason
that we are happy because Lula everybody
knows about him everybody respect him
it's what we need someone who respected
the population the Brazilian but this is
divided the country virtually in half
it's really really close there's a lot
of people like
um president boltonaro as well
but in Brazil it's worse around the
world it's
very very
[Applause]
it's very very different
for us because our president just kind
and make some joke with the people that
was dying and will Lulu be good yeah
he's the best one for us
to represent the people in Brazil all
right
all right thank you very much oh it's
going to be quite a night here as you
might expect as I say we're expecting
Lulu here at some point but we went to
hear from the former president bolsonaro
as well it could still be very tenseless